can we talk about written house for a
minute because i think he there's gonna
charge him no there's
there's a new as an update on the car
right now stuff he won't be charged in
illinois
yeah did you hear about it jack that
means
there's a narrative debunked that he
crossed state lines the gun to go to a
protest
illinois straight up said there's no
evidence to suggest he had a gun in
illinois at all
he just showed up in wisconsin somebody
he was working he was working
in in kenosha yeah i think the i think
you know this kind of wraps up to the
earlier stuff we were talking about just
with tearing statues down the riots the
unrest the creepy weird ideologies
i was talking to i was actually talking
to cnn reporter recently uh like the
other day for quite some time this is
funny
like oh you're not you're in trouble
maybe maybe i'm like maybe they're
actually trying to do a story and
they're lying to me about like just
trying to
have a conversation maybe it's all bunk
or whatever i don't care i'll talk to
people
right and so you know they were asking
about what's going on and stuff
and i asked them you know about kyle
renthouse
of course of course i said do you know
about the security guard in denver
yeah and i was like and you know those
two stories have in common
kyle right now wasn't a white
supremacist the security guard wasn't
anti-fun
they were normies they were normies who
came out with
guns and shot people on the other side
for whatever reason whatever you i'm i'm
not trying to equivocate the morality of
each incident they're different
but but the senior reporter actually was
the one who brought up the car written
house wasn't a white supremacist
saying like yeah yeah like everyone's
trying to claim that written house is
like a white supremacist
no he was he was a kid who came out with
a gun and you know was was like
got into it with people and then people
got shot and i'm like exactly
and then the cnn reporter was like
that's scarier it's scarier that it was
just some regular kid who worked for a
local as a local lifeguard
who came out with a gun that's scary and
then i was like and that's the denver
security guard
this like bernie bro guy not super he
like people are trying to act like he's
antifa
because i i guess they want tribalist
points to like make antifa look bad
he was a bernie bro he was a bernie bro
and he was very active during occupy
wall street but for the past several
years he was working on a farm
selling goat milk and chicken eggs or
something like that eggs
and uh i i i saw a post about like him
and his girlfriend the things they did
over the past several years
unlicensed got a job as a contractor and
shot a trump supporter in the face
now here's the crazy thing about that
denver guy but had he been
out in the protest before being
violent or doing anything i seem to have
seen
images collages of him at a various
number of events
ten years ago is that was that what's
wrong with a bunch of photos from him
during occupy wall street yeah in 2011
2012.
so look it's scarier that he was a
he was not anti-fun yeah he wasn't
organized he wasn't out with black-clad
revolutionary communists and
socialists he was a bernie bro watching
leftist youtube videos
and he went to a trump to a trump rally
and he shot a dude in the face
he went to a copper rally a pro police
rally i think it's both it's like
scarier but it's also not scarier
because
it's it sucks to see people that aren't
already radicalized
do stuff like that but gang violence is
terrifying too
so i think you know i mean it's hard to
say which would be worse
i think it's pretty horrible sure but i
think it's scarier that regular people
are now being pulled in
yeah i mean that's the american middle
militia system is supposed to be
american people defending themselves i
mean i
totally agree with you it's terrifying
that shouldn't happen
that's that's a weird word random people
coming out
and for whatever reason being put in a
situation where they have to do it or
they feel they have to do it
that's that's scary man i i remember
talking about this stuff back in like
2017 2018
and i had so many people say like oh tim
the proud boys fighting with antifa
is not that big of a deal most people
don't know or care who they are
okay well now what about some random kid
in antioch illinois and what about some
like bernie bro working as a security
guard
no violence is there regarding written
house too i want to go into it a little
bit more
um so they they i think you might i
don't think we talked about on this show
yet but
the guy that was coming up after him got
charged right so there's new charges
yeah new charges whoa the guy got shot
in the bicep that guy got you no
the guy who fired the first shot got
charged so this is this is from
cassandra
yeah so i i like i always say this i
don't like the gateway pundit man
we do like cassandra but we do but yes
we do like cassandra fairbanks she does
she does a pretty good job and she has
the the charging documents
okay so the first dude i forgot what his
name is like uh joshua
zaminski or something yeah yeah is that
his name yeah well josh yeah
that was his name yeah i'm sorry i'm
sorry i'm just like agreeing with you
oh i i don't know if i don't know if i
was getting his name right do you want
you want to pull that or something i
could pull up yeah
uh so he fired an air a shot around into
the air
triggering kyle to turn around and then
rosenbaum reached for his gun and kyle
went pop pop
dude goes down and i think that's going
to slam dunk his self-defense case yeah
i think that the only thing he'll end up
actually sitting on for the most part is
going to be
unlawfully like you know he was supposed
to be hearing a weapon right
but the fact that they're charging the
other dude for shooting
come on you can't deny self-defense then
right someone fired a gunshot he turned
around
i was watching all those live streams
live that night
and man i felt like of course not there
not the same but i
felt like the energy like people didn't
know the chaos the shots going off
live streams people running down the
street the whole thing it all of it rang
to me
self-defense as i was watching it quote
in real time over the streams
and uh poor kids 17 years old yeah but
when people
your point is that he's a regular kid
yeah and he believed that he needed to
defend
private property from the mob they had
just
all over the place they were gonna they
were gonna blow up the gas station
burning down
whole fields full of cars and buildings
and police stations in the whole thing
and the cops weren't stopping them no
nobody's stopping them
that's why i think we're we're headed
towards
uh man it's not supposed to be a
pessimistic thing but
you know calamity
yeah because because well hold on think
about this yeah you've got
uh the social media companies
actively shutting down a story that
makes joe biden look
really really bad right what can the
right do to counter the fact that you've
got
people laughing in their faces
figuratively about how they're cheating
about how they're like there is nothing
you can say that we will ever allow
and we are going to win and there's
nothing you can do to stop us the
rioters have gone out for now 135 plus
days
smashing breaking destroying and they're
laughing saying we're going to keep
letting them go and there is nothing you
can do to stop us
and trump's trying deputizing these cops
in certain areas
but what worries me is what do you
where do you think it goes if if the
right keeps getting told you can't speak
and and we're going to burn down your
neighborhood what do you think what do
you think happens
i think well on one hand i think that
what i see happening already
is that people are forming their own
communities right they're already
getting together with the idea of
socializing
being professional working with having
their own media environments their own
information their own sense making
teams their own sort of communities to
to actually put up a barrier between
themselves
and the rest of the world now that's not
going to solve your legal issues or
constitutional issues or whatever else
there's so many complications when you
start trying to think about oh a civil
war it's not going to be anything like
the you know 1860s it's not even going
to be anything like world war ii it's
going to be
some weird hybrid thing of like
afghanistan
where there's you're here they're
everywhere we're all everywhere it's all
happening
all the time and for me personally i'm
thinking in my mind we need to start a
new
a new phase in american history
re-settle
america repopulate america there's so
much land
so many places to go so many great
things to see in places to live
that we need to just have a movement to
resettle america
and actually just start anew and you can
do it
in some places today but if there's if
we're going to sit here and try to
predict
how the country comes apart i think we
can't i think it's unpredictable you're
right we could set up smaller
communities all over the country with
magnetic transportation super fast
trains from community community with
solar powered water condensation in
areas and you could start setting up
with our technology and solar power
new communities yes remember the first
time i came on the show i was all about
the 90 acres for
50 000 homesteading yeah 50 000 person
medieval town is all you need 90 acres
so this has been on my mind how it
shakes out electorally how it shakes out
with the military it's all
it's it's it's tribal now it's networked
it's not geographically centered
you've got people in the cities that see
it one way people in the country
it's not gonna there's not gonna just be
like a oh this side the mississippi
red the mississippi blue it's not it's
just not gonna happen
one problem i'm having is that i'm
moving states and i can't vote i i want
set up to vote in my old state
and but i'm changing states right before
the election and now it's like if i vote
in my old state but i'm a resident of my
new state they might come after me
um so i'm just not going to vote because
it's too risky and that's ridiculous
that i'm an american citizen
and i can't vote because i've moved
states well i
what that you've got to research what
the legality is and make sure you do it
right but i can't
i got to get my license i can't wait
another month and a half
before i change my i'm no no i have to
move forward with my life and
that's setting my voting ability uh down
so you just vote where you're registered
i think you should be able to vote as an
american i don't think it matters where
you live on this soil no i disagree with
that why
because for one because larger denser
wealthier populations strip the rights
away from smaller
but why does why does a guy in my old
town represent me more than a guy and
this like why can't i just pick the
person that represents me the most
because there are small areas that are
that are impoverished and have limited
resources
and if we don't have the barriers you
end up with
los angeles and san diego voting away
the water surface water rights from
tulare county and that literally
happened
so then you have a bunch of poor migrant
families who one day turn their water
fast on and no water comes out why
because the cities are richer and
there's more people and they won the
right to take the water away
so so we create jurisdictions to protect
the minority that's what this country is
built upon that's the point of like part
partly the point of virtual college so
yeah it's very important
that you vote based on where you are and
who represents your area
so what's up with gerrymandering where
they'll take a area that was previously
functional and then they'll split it so
that certain people
now have control of the area it's it's
gerrymandering has become extremely
corrupted yeah that's kind of ruined
local voting
i mean yeah absolutely sort of like
court packing at the local legislative
level but
let's just carry your question out a
little bit farther i think the first
thing that happens that we see
is just a decreased
reliance upon the federal government
right your corporations take more
power your local communities take more
power your associations
begin to to create more power and then
you just start thinking about the
federal government
less and less unless you're the one
who's like co-opted the federal
government to do your bidding
but it's really i there's because the
future's so unpredictable
what i have decided to do is to take
action today and to build a community
starting today
so what i'm doing is i'm building a
community of men with like-minded values
shared values is how you're going to
start to create new
communities based on shared values
because one of the things that's very
clear is that we don't have common
united you know common values
uh there's the common values that once
made us a country
seem to be no longer so we need to find
people that you have common values with
and then begin to build
a new a new civilization website
uh regarding that too what is that
website oh right so the liminal order is
the organization that i'm talking about
and it's founded on our three core
values of brotherhood masculinity and
sovereignty so we're very focused on
building our own personal sovereignty we
have hundreds of guys around the country
even around the world at this point
and the long-term goal is to create a
situation which you can socialize
work with engage with do service for
and just have a life with people who
share your values right off the jump
well one of one of the big issues that's
that's like one of the biggest problems
we have is tribalism
yes so it's only going to get worse yeah
yeah because technology the technology
is is
feeding the tribalism now so i have a
guest coming up on my podcast tomorrow
john rob as a matter of fact who is an
expert on tribal warfare insurgencies
counterinsurgencies network warfare etc
and we're going to talk tomorrow
about this very question actually and
what he believes is that tribalism is on
the on the rise
because of the imagery and the
empathetic triggers that we can send
around to people instantaneously so you
see a video
and it triggers an empathetic reaction
in you and you know that if it triggers
this sympathetic reaction you're part of
this tribe and if it triggers a
different reaction you're part of that
tribe
and so these images keep coming out and
they keep coming out and they keep
triggering us and triggering us
we start to make a pattern and we start
to recognize the pattern and then we
sort
according to these tribes and they're
networked so it's like all online
and then these things are now emerging
and we see these alliances right so
black lives matter antifa they're not
the same but they have an alliance right
now because they have a common goal
right and so the corporations also have
a common goal which is to diminish the
power of the federal government
that's why you see the corporations blm
and antifa all on the same team today
because they all have the same common
goal they have what's called network
alignment
so that's the future of our politics and
of our populace and our civilization is
like
these tribes which are built on
empathetic triggers and reactions and
then they emerge
and then they have alignment and then
that's how you have these alliances
they're not going to last forever but
for right now
that's why you see like blm antifa
corporations all together on the same
side
where can people follow your podcast the
podcast is jack murphy live on youtube
jackmurphylive.com is the website follow
me on twitter at jack murphy live
we're going live tomorrow at 11 with
john robb i mean john robb is a special
forces guy he served all over the world
he wrote a book called a brave new war
where he studied tribalism and networked
counterinsurgencies in in iraq and
afghanistan as well
and we're seeing that here we're seeing
it already happen here antifa is like
isis basically
in the way that they form and the way
that they arrange themselves and the way
they conduct themselves
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when
we go live don't forget to subscribe hit
the like button
hit the notification bell and we are
also available on all podcast platforms
for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time